[Music]
who Yvette you are beyond ready for the
release of descendants three fans
everywhere holding their breath waiting
for the next chapter but what happens
after the third movie if you love The
Descendants hit that subscribe button to
stay up to date now let's get into what
happens to mal after descendants 3 we
cannot wait for descendants 3 we're
hooked on the story and are dying to
know what happens to our favorite
characters next there are a lot of
theories as to what will happen in the
third movie we know mal encounters a
strange blue light and calls it dad
we can all guess that there will be an
epic showdown with uma there are plenty
of fan theories about what new
characters will meet a few new
characters have been confirmed and are
guaranteed to appear in the film we know
we'll be meeting Hades and dr. faciliate
name is Hades Lord of the Dead hi Hayden
Audrey will make her big return to our
don and with all of those details
confirm for what will happen in the next
movie we can't help but wonder what will
happen after the next chapter ends mal
is a fan favorite and central to the
story so what happens to her after the
descendants three The Big Sleep ends
we'd like to think that after she
finally gets to meet her father that he
remains in her life Maleficent said that
mal got all of her good traits from her
human father we all know you can't trust
everything a villain says what dear old
mom
so there's no telling if mouths dad
really is human we can't even be sure
he's a good guy he did like Maleficent
after all we hope for mouths sake that
her dad is awesome mouths dad could be a
pretty good guy considering how very not
rotten to the core
his daughter is even with Maleficent
evil influence mal still turned out to
be sweet and honorable are those traits
that mal chose on her own or is her dad
a genuinely nice guy where did she get
all those great qualities whoever Mel's
dad is they have lost time to make up
for they need to get to know each other
and build a relationship after the third
movie mal probably takes some time to
bond with her new family and learn what
a normal parent is like with such a
terrible mother mal really needs a great
relationship with a loving father do you
enjoy watching innocent people suffer
yeah she has a lot of healing to do and
a good dad could help a lot Mel's
meeting her dad isn't the only change
that will likely happen in her life fans
everywhere have their own theories as to
how the story of mal and Ben continues
it's not hard to see where certain parts
of the plot are going there's an epic
love story at the heart of all the
descendants movies after descendants 3
mal will most likely be queen of Aragon
she's been in love with Ben for a long
time this is a Disney story after all so
a happy ending is almost guaranteed
breakups are pretty rare in the disney
world true love always wins the day the
obvious next step of our Don's favorite
couple is a romantic proposal and a big
Royal Wedding honestly who doesn't want
to see mal in a huge purple wedding
dress it's the logical next step and
fans want to see it after the happy
couple is married mal will naturally be
crowned Queen that's a lot of
responsibility but Mel is perfect for
the job as Queen will mal finally lifts
the barrier and set the aisle free both
mal and then know that there are a lot
of kids who deserve a chance they
shouldn't be held accountable for their
parents evil deeds mal could definitely
be the perfect spokesperson for
unification
her marriage to Ben will be a symbol of
cooperation between our Adan and the
aisle Ben wanted to lift the band before
he fell in love with Mal with a VK as
his wife and queen Ben will be more
motivated than ever to lift the barrier
a unified era Don with no threat from
the Isle
sounds like a perfect place to raise a
child once Ben and mal are happily
married in a thriving art on a baby
seems like the most obvious next step
baby we can't help but imagine a perfect
little princess in ruffles and a tiara
or maybe a little prince in blue and
gold
either way Mel and Ben's baby is sure to
be powerful and of course cute the story
must go on and our Don will need a new
generation of kids mal and Ben's
children will live a happy life of
luxury
they'll be royalty in a beautiful
kingdom with loving parents well the
other BK's have their own children for
them to play with how cute would it be
if the lifelong friends had kids that
were best friends to a generation of art
on kids whose parents were born on the
Isle would be the ultimate symbol of
peace between the two cities
if the barrier is lifted and mal has
children would Maleficent finally give
up her wicked ways could mal get the
ultimate happy ending dove Cameron has
said she's got some ideas about where
she'd like to see her character go she
thinks the love story between Ben and
mal is great but she wants to see her
character come into her own we couldn't
agree more Ben is dreamy and their love
is adorable but mal deserves to work on
herself too Dov sees mal really
exploring her power mal has an
incredible amount of magical ability but
it can be unpredictable she needs to
have space and freedom to explore what
she's fully capable of can you imagine
how great mal would be after she fully
embraces her power as Queen and fully in
control now would be an unstoppable
force for good after the third movie
ends
we see mal happy raining over are done
with kindness and intelligence and fully
in control over power The Descendants
movies have fans all over the world
after the first two films the excitement
for the third is insane we can't wait to
see the next chapter of the story and
beyond we will never get sick of our Don
and its residents and that's it for this
peek into the future of The Descendants
we'll see you in the future in the next
video
[Music]